well a metro police officer who lost his  life to kovit 19 was honored today  for his work helping others lieutenant  eric lloyd is one of nearly 300 police  officers across the country  to die of kovitz since the pandemic  began he was the president of the  injured police officers fund  a non-profit that raises money for  families of officers hurt or  killed in the line of duty today they  hosted the heroes live forever  5k walk at police memorial park so we  just wanted to host this event  and get people out and honor our heroes  our everyday heroes as well as ones that  have lost their lives  money raised today will help benefit the  injured police officers fund